Well, the multimillion dollar
question tonight,
will Donald Trump be barred
from New York's luxury
real estate business and forced to pay
perhaps $370 million for falsifying
financial records?
Here to break it all down
and what's at stake.
Shark Tank judge
and chairman of O'Leary Ventures.
Some call and Mr.
Wonderful will come
Kevin O'Leary tonight.
Kevin,
thank you so much for being here today.
I have to ask you, I mean, look,
some people
look at all this and they say,
is this what happens in business?
What Trump has said he's done
or is accused of being done?
You've been doing
real estate for decades.
Does this case strike you as odd
Well, let's leave out Trump for a minute
and let's leave out politics
and just talk about
what happens in real estate
development anywhere.
So if you're a developer
and you've got a building on an on
a block
anywhere in America
and it's worth,
let's say, $500 million
and you want to build a building
right beside it,
you go to the bank and say,
This building is worth $500 million.
I'd like to borrow a construction
finance loan against this asset,
and I want you to tell me
it's worth 500 million to
and the bank negotiates
with you and says, Well,
now we think it's worth 400 million
and you fight it out.
You're always trying to show your assets
in the brightest light
with the sunshine
you can possibly determine for them.
You want them to be worth the very most
because you're only going
to get a 40 or 50% loan to value,
as it's called,
Then you borrow that money
in the case of a $500 million asset,
maybe you get 250 million
and you build a new building
with a construction finance loan.
And so that's what
this case is all about. What?
And by the way, forget about Trump.
Every single real estate developer
everywhere on earth does this.
They always talk about their asset
being worth a lot.
And the bank says, no,
that's just the way it is.
So in this case,
when I'm trying to figure out
and I'm not pro or con
or I don't care about the politics,
who lost money?
Nobody. The bank got paid back.
The construction finance loan
and a new building was built
And if you're going to sue
this case and win,
you've got to sue
every real estate developer everywhere.
This is all they do.
This is what they do.
All day long, every day.
So I don't think this thing
will ever survive appeal regardless
of what the fine is.
This doesn't even make sense.
Now, look,
I know Trump's
got a lot of problems
in other indictments
and everything else, but but this
if you're a real estate developer,
you're watching this.
You're saying, what is this
This is ridiculous.
Well, you know,
the thing
is, most people who are in
this world
are not real estate developers,
and they don't know that this is the way
maybe things are done.
Even if it might be violative of the law.
But the question about who loses money
and I've heard this argument
and he's raised this argument,
others, it raises the argument
that who is a little victim here?
How about the fact that
you can get a tax benefit
for having overvalued
or having a different value
that's actually normal.
Doesn't that deprive
the state of revenue?
Is that enough, do you think?
I know you're laughing.
You bet.
Rich people
problems are very different
than my world. Go ahead.
I mean, I get it.
I get it.
I totally get it.
And you're making a valid point,
but it's humorous in the sense
that you have to sue
every single real estate developer
here in Miami.
In Chicago, in Los Angeles,
in Detroit, in Dallas.
This is what they do every day.
This is what the real estate
game is all about.
It's getting construction
financing to get stabilized assets.
When a building is fully leased out
and everybody's renting it
and you've got offices
or you've got apartments in it,
it's called a stable asset.
And you value it
and you go to the bank and say,
this assets asset is worth 500 million
and I want to borrow 250 million
against it in the bank.
Always negotiates with you.
Everybody understands how this works.
And that's why
I think it's going to be very,
very hard to make this stick in reality.
Later.
This is this is not of all the things
that Trump's being accused of
and being litigated for and indicted for.
This is not his problem.
This is this.
He's got much worse problems than this.
This is for real estate developers.
This is a joke.
It's fascinating to me
to hear this perspective
because you don't often
hear it from that particular angle.
And of course, you wonder
if everyone's doing it.
And one would have to sue
everybody does that mean
that they got to have
a bigger prosecutor's office
or that the laws
have to change to make it?
I mean,
you cannot do like,
what is the solution here?
You get punished for it
or you shouldn't do it or you know what?
It should be okay.
The first question, is
everybody doing it in real estate?
Yes.
Everybody's doing it
not only domestically
all around the world.
This is how it works.
Okay.
Now, you don't want to be Donald Trump
and get embroiled in what looks like
I mean, it looks to me
in this presidential race
and I'm not in favor of this,
that the courts are being used to try
and sway voters
on both sides of the equation.
I don't understand why
we're trying to win
you know, impeach Biden.
What a waste of time.
And I
and his son and all this stuff
and all of this litigation on Trump
hasn't moved the needle
for either of these candidates.
It does.
People don't care about this noise
anymore.
And it's obvious
when you look at these poll results.
And so why keep doing it?
I mean, let the voters vote
and decide on the merits of both.
I'd rather hear policy.
I'd rather not hear
about Trump's real estate
woes in New York.
I'd like to hear his tax plan.
I want to hear about security
at the border.
I'd like to hear foreign policy
from both of these candidates
so I can make a decision as a voter
on which of these people
should be president.
And the rest of this stuff
is just horrific noise.
When in America
do we sue sitting presidents
and former presidents?
We've never done this before.
This is really bad
for the American brand.
This is kind of
it feels like Venezuela
to me or something. This is nuts.
I'd rather
we're so close to the election.
We're months away.
Let's talk policy.
Give me some meat on the bone.
This stuff's getting too crazy.
Oh, bless your heart, Mr. Wonderful.
You want to know
the policy in politics, huh?
What a Washington, D.C. that would be.
That would be wonderful, wouldn't it?
Nice to see you.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate
hearing your perspective.
Because, you know, I lean into it.
Mr. Wonderful. Thank you so much.